Did you,
are you scared of artificial life,
artificial intelligence?
Um,
you,
I must scare the shit out of me.
Yeah.
When he talked about it,
like he,
he talks about it like we're in the opening scene of a science fiction movie
where he's trying to warn people and then they don't listen to,
to the genius and it goes south.
So depends.
I Chad at Ebay on this,
um,
the royal society in London a few weeks ago and uh,
they,
so he's treat now at the moment what,
what people tend to be frightened of a general Ai's,
oh,
I AGI,
they called artificial general intelligence,
which is like what we talked about earlier,
a human like capability thing.
Yes.
Um,
and we miles away from that.
We don't know how to do it.
We haven't got them and we miles away.
So at the moment,
artificial intelligence is expert systems and very focused systems that do
particular things.
You can be scared of them in a limited economic sense because they're going to
displace people's jobs.
And actually,
interestingly in this panel discussion we had,
it's going to be like what you might call middle class jobs in the UK.
So white collar jobs.
It's not why people are interested in universal basic income to sort of replace
money that's going to be lost because there will be no jobs for all these
people.
Otherwise we have just a mass catastrophe.
They're very good.
Someone said that these systems,
artificial intelligence systems at the moment,
they're very good at doing things like law lawyer's work.
So they're very good at reading contracts and things like that.
There's interesting cause it's a,
it's a revolution.
It's not like the industrial revolution.
Where is manual labor that gets hit necessarily.
This is kind of interesting because it hits that kind of intermediate level that
usually escapes.
Um,
so you're right,
one of the answers is to tax,
there was a example was a robot tax.
So in a car factory you say to the manufacturer,
well okay you can have a robot.
What?
You pay the robot the same as you pay a person and then that money goes into
funding universal basic income or something like that.
So I think the,
there's gotta be an economic change because these systems will be there.
But all the experts I spoke to agreed that the idea of a terminate a style,
general intelligence taking over the world is miles away.
And um,
so whilst we might start thinking about the regulation,
it's not going to happen soon is the general point.
I think so I would disagree with him on that.
I think,
I think it's too far in the future.
At the moment.
I thought I might be one of those people.
That's an ad.
It's going to be all right.
And then,
and then,
you know,
my iPhone takes me out on the way to the airport.
Yeah.
Thing.
I mean you,
it's our choice at the moment,
isn't it?
I mean don't,
don't give your iPhone a laser for example.
And it doesn't matter if he goes crazy and tries to take over the world.
I know,
I know that's a bit facetious.
Cause they can,
he would say they could take over the power grids and all that kind of stuff I
guess.
But well it's these concepts that are really hard to visualize,
like sorta occurred.
Swilles idea of the exponential increase of technology leading us to a point in
the near future where you're gonna be able to download your consciousness into a
computer.
You talked to computer experts,
it like this.
Now way we're miles away from that on you're a scientist or scientists that you
knew one brain cell properly.
We can't,
but Kurzweil's convinced that what's going to happen is that as technology
increases,
it increases in this wildly exponential way where we really can't visualize it.
We can't even imagine how much advancement will take place over 50 years,
but in those 50 years something's going to happen.
That radically changes our idea of what's possible.
And I think Ilan shares this idea as well,
that it's going to sneak up on us so quickly that when it does go live,
it'll be too late.
Yeah,
I mean it's worth putting the,
the the framework in place.
I think the regulatory framework,
even as you said,
for the more realistic problem,
which is people's jobs are going to get displaced.
Yes,
there's a great,
um,
I always had a thing in some,
someone said,
I kind of,
it was,
but they said that the GRE,
it was a politician.
The,
the job of the innovation system is to create jobs faster than it destroys them.
So you've always got to remember that as a government and as regulators,
if you're going to allow technologies into the marketplace at destroy people's
jobs,
it is your responsibility to find a way of replacing those jobs or compensate in
those people as you said,
otherwise you can break down.
So for regular human being,
those that people need some meaning,
like they just giving them income I think is just going to,
I mean it's just my speculation,
but it can create mass despair.
Even if we provide them,
you provide them with food and shelter,
they need,
people need things to do.
So it's,
yeah,
there's going to be some sort of a demand to find meaning for people,
give them occupations,
give them something,
some task.
Let's say it seems to be one of the critical parts of being a person.
And so we need things to do that we find meaning in,
you know,
like you were talking about where the only things that we know of that have
meaning that find meaning and share meaning and believe in that we're gonna need
something like that.
If universal basic income comes along,
I don't think it's going to be enough to just feed people and house them.
They're going to want something to do.
If a,
you know,
a person is,
uh,
you're doing something for an occupation and this is your identity,
and then all of sudden that occupation becomes irrelevant because the computer
does it faster,
cheaper,
quicker.
These people are going to have this incredible feeling of despair and just not
being valuable.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
well,
the utopian,
so the version of this is that everybody gets to do what we're doing now,
right?
She's make a living.
So I think in creating that kind of,
you know,
so that's the,
the Utopian ideal is you don't need to do that stuff.
The job that you don't really want to do in the factory.
Right.
You can do the thing that humans are best at that,
but I agree.
That's a very utopian view.
Yeah.
Does everybody want to do that or does everybody have their mindset?
Well,
maybe because went to education.
If everybody had an interest like that,
if everybody went on to make pottery and painting and doing all these different
things that they've always really wanted to do and their needs are met by,
you know,
the universal basic income money that they receive every month.
But boy,
there's a lot of people I don't think have those desires or needs and to sort of
force it onto them at age 55 or whatever it's going to be.
Yeah,
it seems to be very,
very difficult.
Yeah.
I agree.
It's a big challenge,
but I think that in concept at least,
it's inevitable that we do have some sort of an artificial intelligence that
resembles us or that resemble something like x Mokena.
If people choose to create that,
we choose to create it in our own image.
But that's very godlike,
isn't it?
God created us in his own image.
Yeah.
And,
and again,
yeah.
I don't know that when I talk to people in the field,
as you probably have,
most of them say don't know how to do it.
Yes,
it's really right.
It's going to be miles away.
So maybe I'm hiding my head in the sand a bit,
but I don't think so.
I think it's,
I think we'll know it when I don't think anyone's going to do it accidentally.
Right.
So I don't think it's just suddenly going to be upon us.
I,
I think we will see,
we will see ourselves getting,
acquiring that capability.
We'll see ourselves getting close.
We'll see those systems beginning to emerge and then we will think about it.
I think 200 years ago,
if you wanted a photograph of something,
you want a picture of something,
you had to draw it.
I mean,
there was no photography 200 years ago.
Yeah.
I mean just think of that is almost inconceivable.
No automobiles,
no photography.
What was automobile?
Maybe there was some sort of machines that drove people around.
Right.
Something close there.
Some trains earlier than that,
right?
You go back 500 years,
you have almost nothing.
Yeah.
That's crazy how we've been quick so fast.
It's so fast.
I mean,
and then this what we're doing right now,
there's people right now in their car that are streaming this,
so they're in their car and they're listening as they're driving on the road.
Maybe they have a Tesla,
maybe they have an electric car.
They're driving down the road streaming to people talking where it's ones and
Zeros that are broken down and there's some audible form and you can listen to
it in your car is bananas.
Yeah,
I agree.
We've been quick so quick.
Well,
I think they will,
you know,
the Internet,
I mean,
it's,
uh,
not long.
I mean,
I remember it being invented.
Yeah.